vamos a resolver el siguiente problema
nos dicen que tomemos un número primo
impar un número primo impar digo todos
los números primos son impares el único
que no es impar es el 2 entonces esto
nos está él nos está diciendo que vamos
a elegir un número primo que no sea el 2
en eso se resume muy bien y vamos a
considerar tp el siguiente conjunto de
matrices de tamaño 2 x 2 pp es el
conjunto de matrices que se ven de la
siguiente forma un número a b c y
repetimos el número a es decir en la
diagonal tenemos el mismo número ahora
bien nos dice además que a veces son
números números naturales o buenos
números enteros que van de cero ap - uno
puede ser 0 1 2 3 4 etcétera hasta p
menos 1 recordemos que p es un número
primo nos dice entonces el número de
matrices
en tp tales que son simétricas anti
simétricas o ambas y que además su
determinante sea divisible entre p es y
nos dan estas cuatro opciones así que lo
que tenemos que hacer primero es ver de
todas estas matrices cuáles son
simétricas anti simétricas o ambas y una
vez hecho eso también hay que revisar
que su determinante sea divisible entre
p entonces sería bueno recordar cuáles
son las matrices simétricas entonces
tenemos una matriz es simétrica sí qué
pasa
imagínense que tienen aquí ustedes su
matriz vamos a hacerlo así a b c a muy
bien y una matriz es simétrica si
coincide con esta matriz
es decir cambiamos los elementos que
están en la digamos vamos a llamarle
está la anti diagonal muy bien que son
estos dos b y c eso nos está diciendo
que la matriz transpuesta es igual a la
matriz original la matriz transpuesta es
aquella que los los renglones los
conviertes en columnas verdad por
ejemplo aquí tenemos a b que es renglón
se convierte en columna lo mismo con sea
se convierte en columna entonces si
tenemos una matriz simétrica déjenme ir
bajando un poco el ejercicio si tenemos
una matriz simétrica esto nos dice que
si son iguales son iguales entrada y
entrada por entrada entonces a es
igualada eso es claro pero aquí nos está
diciendo que b debe ser igual a c esta
igualdad nos dice lo mismo que b es
igual a c entonces de aquí concluimos
que si una matriz es simétrica b tiene
que ser igual a c vamos a ver qué son
las matrices anti simétricas
anti simétrica
anti simétrica una matriz y una matriz
es anti simétrica si resulta ser así la
matriz ave
a es igual nos tomamos su transpuesta
pero con signo negativo es menos a menos
se ve menos a si te das cuenta lo que
hicimos fue tomarnos la transpuesta y
multiplicar por menos entonces nos dice
que una matriz es anti simétrica sí sí
sí ella misma es menos su transpuesta
ahora fijémonos en esto tiene que ser
igual a menos a a debe ser igual a menos
a y sólo hay un número que es igual a
menos el mismo y es el número es el cero
entonces a tiene que ser cero entonces
nuestra matriz tiene un cero en la
diagonal ahora bien nos dice que b tiene
que ser igual a menos c
de igual a menos de hielo lo único que
podemos digamos deducir de esto ahora
bien la segunda parte nos dice que su
determinante debe ser divisible entre p
entonces
recordemos que el determinante de una
matriz a es digamos el determinante de
esta ave
y el determinante se calcula como el
producto de los elementos de la diagonal
que en este caso es a por a que es a
cuadrada
- menos los que están en la anti
diagonal que es b x se ve por c entonces
este numerito de aquí en cualquiera de
los dos casos debe ser divisible entre p
entonces vamos a ver cada uno de los
casos qué pasa si tenemos una matriz
simétrica si tenemos una matriz
simétrica quién es el determinante de a
es a cuadrada
menos b por c pero ve por c como ves
igual hace esto es b cuadrada entonces
este número a cuadrada menos b cuadrada
debe ser divisible entre p pero lo que
podemos hacer en este momento es
factorizar esto podemos factorizar a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada ahora bien qué
pasa con el determinante de una matriz
anti simétrica pues entonces nuevamente
tenemos ahora
el determinante de esta matriz va a ser
ahora pero es cero entonces tendremos
cero - b por c - b porque vamos a
escribirlo así y ahora usamos que ve es
menos c aunque entonces tengo menos
-
o bueno vamos a ponerlo en términos de
tv
si ves menos entonces se es igual a
menos b esto es equivalente y entonces
tenemos menos ve menos ve - ve por c
pero se es menos b entonces tenemos
menos b por menos de eso es b cuadrada
aquí nos está diciendo que ve cuadrada
tiene que ser divisible entre p y eso ya
nos está poniendo las restricciones del
problema ahora veamos esta parte dijimos
que vamos a factorizar lo y eso lo
podemos expresar como a más ve por a
menos b si es una diferencia de
cuadrados se factorizar como binomios
conjugados y esto debe ser igual debe
ser igual a un ap por algún múltiplo por
algún número acá esto es lo que
significa que sea divisible entre p
entonces fíjense que si p por otro
número es este producto quiere decir que
te divide alguno de ellos no puede pasar
que por ejemplo una parte de vida
este y otra parte de pedí vida a este
otro verdad por qué pues porque es un
número primo entonces si p es un número
primo forzosamente debe dividir a alguno
de ellos puede que divida a ambos pero
al menos a uno entonces sí divide al
menos a uno la pregunta puede ser es
bueno en qué condiciones a menos b a
menos b es divisible entre p puede ser
bajo qué condiciones es divisible entre
p
esto es pregunta entonces si nos fijamos
a y b son más chicos que p de hecho
están entre 0 y p menos 1 y eso va a ser
fundamental en el resto del ejercicio
porque si hay veces son más chicos que p
piensa en un número a ok y ahora le vas
a restar
otro número
muy bien entonces y eso por supuesto
digamos lo más pequeño que podemos
obtener sería que fuera 0 y b fuera p
menos 1 en cuyo caso sí si le restamos
eso tendríamos menos p más 1 que de
todos modos es más chico por perdón es
más grande que menos pero el punto es
que el único número que es divisible
entre p de esta forma es cuando a menos
de 0 a menos b tiene que ser
y eso nuevamente pues porque lo voy a
poner un poco más a la derecha - ve
tiene que ser cero porque eso digamos si
a es cero ibex -1 ni siquiera alcanzamos
el número menos p que sería un número
divisible entre p así que está este es
el resultado que tenemos y esto que nos
está diciendo si a menos b es igual a
cero
sí sí llámenos ve es igual a cero quiere
decir que es igual a b y entonces
simplemente la única condición son todos
los valores en donde a es igual a b y
esos son valores verdad tenemos aquí de
0 ap - 1 pues nos podemos elegir aquí
bueno tenemos un valor dos valores tres
valores si nos damos cuenta tenemos de
posibles combinaciones para ahí ve si
tienen que ser los mismos entonces aquí
tenemos pe posibilidades verdad tantas
posibilidades como puede tomar valores a
ok entonces ya que tenemos esto vamos a
ver qué pasa en qué condiciones además
ve es éste divisible entre p entonces a
más b además de no puede ser 0 verdad si
a más de 0 quiere decir que ambos son 0
y eso ya está contado en este caso muy
bien entonces no vamos a considerar que
además b es cero entonces el único
número que puede ser divisible entre p
verdad el mayor valor que puede tomar
además ve es cuando ambos son ambos
valen p menos uno que si los sumas nos
quedan dos p menos dos que es más chico
que dos p entonces la única posibilidad
que tenemos es que además b sea igual
voy a hacerlo incluso más abajo para
tener espacio la única posibilidad es
que a más b sea igual a p muy bien
entonces también hay que notar que no
puede pasar que ambos sean iguales
fíjense si es igual a b quiere decir que
dos veces a es igual a p pero si dos
veces a es igual a p pasamos el 2
dividiendo hay que decir que a es igual
a p entre 2 muy bien entonces esto de
aquí me está diciendo mucho esto de aquí
me está diciendo mucho porque sería
divisible entre 2 pero dijimos que es un
número impar entonces y esto no puede
ser por lo tanto a no puede ser igual a
b vamos a quitar este argumento
que haya quedado muy claro y ahora
entonces nos fijamos en qué condiciones
además ve puede ser igual a p y no
tenemos que pues una vez que nosotros
elijamos un valor de a por ejemplo si a
es 1 pues entonces b tiene que ser p - 1
para que la suma mdp
entonces determinando a inmediatamente
está obligado el valor de b y entonces
uno diría bueno pues tengo pe
posibilidades de valores para pero no
puede ser igual a b entonces eso nos
resta una posibilidad y simplemente nos
quedan p - un posibilidades
posibilidades ahora de estas dos las
sumamos y tenemos todo verdad porque si
sumamos estas dos entonces tenemos p más
p menos uno
entonces esto es 2 p menos uno
deben ser el número de posibilidades muy
bien entonces aquí está el total de
posibilidades de este caso vamos
rápidamente a ver qué pasa con con con
el caso anti simétrico en este caso
resulta que ve cuadrada es el que tiene
que ser divisible entre p es decir de
cuadrada debe ser p por algún otro
número entonces aquí aquí nos está
diciendo que b por b es divisible es
divisible entre p
es divisible entre p nuevamente pues
entonces p tiene que dividir haber
necesariamente verdad entonces p divide
a b se divide a b entonces
bajo qué condiciones ve es divisible
entre p nuevamente vemos que b tiene que
ser más chico que p nuestro número primo
y no hay un número que sea divisible
entre p excepto el 0 verdad el 0 sí lo
puedo dividir entre p p por 0 es 0
entonces es divisible entre p así que el
único valor es que b sea igual a cero
entonces uno podría pensar que tenemos
otro chance pero recordemos que a ya era
cero entonces hay b son iguales y son
cero en este caso ya está incluido en
este de acá entonces no es cierto que
tengamos que agregar otra otra
posibilidad simplemente ya estaba
contado en estos que teníamos acá así
que como ya estaban contados
en los casos pasados el total de
posibilidades son 2 p - 1 muy bien donde
es simétrica o anti simétrica y el
determinante es divisible entre p así
que esa corresponde a nuestra opción de
y con eso terminamos el problema